[Music]
welcome to the future of life Institute
podcast
I'm Lucas Perry today we have a
conversation with Sam Harris where we
get into issues related to global
priorities effective altruism and
existential risk in particular this
podcast covers the critical importance
of improving our ability to communicate
and converge on the truth animal
suffering in both wild animals and
factory farmed animals global poverty
artificial general intelligence risk and
AI alignment as well as ethics and some
thoughts on Sam's book the moral
landscape if you find this podcast
valuable you can subscribe or follow us
on your preferred listening platform
like on Apple podcasts Spotify
SoundCloud or whatever your preferred
podcasting app is you can also support
us by leaving a review before we get
into it I would like to echo two
announcements from previous podcasts if
you've been tuned into the FLI podcast
recently you can skip ahead just a bit
the first is that there is an ongoing
survey for this podcast where you can
give me feedback and voice your opinion
about content this goes a super long way
for helping me to make the podcast
valuable for everyone you can find a
link for the survey about this podcast
and the description of wherever you
might be listening the second
announcement is that at the future of
life Institute we are in the midst of
our search for the 2020 winner of the
future of life award the future of life
award is a $50,000 prize that we give
out to an individual who without having
received much recognition at the time of
their actions has helped to make today
dramatically better than it may have
been otherwise the first two recipients
of the future of life award were Vasili
arkhipov and stanislav petrov two heroes
of the nuclear age both took actions at
great personal risk to possibly prevent
an all-out nuclear war the third
recipient was dr. Matthew meselson who
spearheaded the international ban on
bioweapons right now we're not sure who
to give the 2020 future of life award to
that's where you come in if you know of
an unsung hero
has helped to avoid global catastrophic
disaster or who has done incredible work
to ensure a beneficial future of life
please head over to the future of life
award page and submit a candidate for
consideration the link for that page is
on the page for this podcast or in the
description of wherever you might be
listening if your candidate is chosen
you will receive $3,000 as a token of
our appreciation
we're also incentivizing the search via
mi t--'s successful red balloon strategy
were the first to nominate the winner it
gets three thousand dollars as mentioned
but there are also tier two payouts
we're the first to invite the nomination
winner gets $1,500 whoever first invited
them gets $750 and whoever first invited
them gets 375 dollars and so on you can
find details about that on the future of
life award page sam harris has a PhD in
neuroscience from UCLA and is the author
of 5 New York Times bestsellers his
books include the end of faith letter to
a Christian nation the moral landscape
free will lying waking up and Islam in
the future of tolerance with Maajid
Nawaz Sam hosts the making sense podcast
and is also the creator of the waking up
app which is for anyone who wants to
learn to meditate in a modern scientific
context Sam has practiced meditation for
more than 30 years and studied with many
Tibetan Indian Burmese and Western
meditation teachers both in the United
States and abroad and with that here's
my conversation with sam harris starting
off here trying to get a perspective on
what matters most in the world and
global priorities or crucial areas for
consideration what do you see as the
most important problems in the world
today there is one fundamental problem
which is encouragingly or depressingly
non-technical depending on your view of
item it should be such a simple problem
to solve but it's seeming more or less
totally intractable and that's just the
problem of communication the problem of
persuasion the problem of getting people
to agree on a
shared consensus view of reality and to
acknowledge basic facts and to have
their probability assessments of various
outcome to converge through honest
conversation politics is obviously the
great confounder of this meaning of the
minds of it our failure to fuse
cognitive horizons through conversation
is reliably derailed by politics but
there are other sorts of ideology that
do this just as well religion being
perhaps first among them and so it seems
to me that the first problem we need to
solve the place where we need to make
progress and we need to fight for every
inch of ground and try not to lose it
again and again is in our ability to
talk to one another about what is true
and what is worth paying attention to to
get our norms to align on a similar
picture of what matters basically you
know value alignment not with super
intelligent AI but with other human
beings that's the master riddle we have
to solve and our failure to solve it
prevents us from doing anything else
that requires cooperation that's where
I'm most concerned obviously technology
influences it social media and even AI
am in the algorithms behind the gaming
of everyone's attention and all of that
is influencing our public conversation
but it really is a very a push concern
and we have to get our arms around it so
that's quite interesting and not the
answer that I was expecting I think that
that sounds like quite the crucial
stepping stone like the fact that
climate change isn't something that
we're able to agree upon and as a matter
of political opinion drives me crazy and
that's one of many different global
catastrophic or existential risk issues
yeah the kovat pandemic has made me
especially skeptical of our agreeing to
do anything about climate change the
fact that we can't persuade people about
the basic facts of Epidemiology when
this thing is literally coming in
through the doors and windows and even
very smart people are now going down the
rabbit hole of
this is on some level a hoax people's
political and economic interest just
bend their view of basic facts I'm it's
not to say that there hasn't been a fair
amount of uncertainty here but it's not
the sort of uncertainty that should give
us these radically different views of
what's happening out in the world here
we have a pandemic moving in real time I
mean where we can see a wave of illness
breaking in Italy a few weeks before it
breaks in New York and again there's
just this Baghdad Bob level of denialism
the prospects of our getting our head
straight with respect to climate change
in light of what's possible in the
middle of a pandemic that seems at the
moment totally far-fetched to me for
something like climate change I really
think a technological elite needs to
just decide it's a problem and decide to
solve it by changing the kinds of
products we create and the way we
manufacture things and we just have to
get out of the politics of it it can't
be a matter of persuading more than half
of American society to make economic
sacrifices for it it's much more along
the lines of just building cars and
other products that are carbon neutral
that people want and solving the problem
that way right incentivizing the
solution by making products that are
desirable and satisfy people's
self-interest yeah yeah I do want to
explore more actual global priorities
this point about the necessity of reason
for being able to at least converge upon
the global priorities that are most
important seems to be the crucial
necessary
stepping stone so before we get into
talking about things like existential
and global catastrophic risk do you see
a way of this project of promoting
reason and good conversation and
converging around good ideas succeeding
or do you have any other things to sort
of add to these instrumental abilities
humanity needs to cultivate for being
able to rally around global priorities
well you know I don't see a lot of
innovation beyond just noticing that
conversation is the only tool we have a
intellectual honesty spread through the
mechanism of conversation is the only
tool we have to converge in these ways I
guess the thing to notice that's
guaranteed to make it difficult is bad
incentives so we should always be
noticing what incentives are doing
behind the scenes to people's cognition
they're things that could be improved in
media I math I think the advertising
model is a terrible system of incentives
for journalists and anyone else who's
spreading information you're
incentivized to create sensational hot
takes and clickbait and personalize
everything just create one lurid
confection after another that really
doesn't get at what's true the fact that
this tribe Eliza's almost every
conversation and forces people to view
it through a political lens the way this
is all amplified by facebook's business
model and the fact that you can sell
political ads on facebook and use their
micro targeting algorithm to frankly
distort people's vision of reality and
get them to vote or not vote based on
some delusion all of this is
pathological and it has to be
disincentivize in some way the business
model of digital media is part of the
problem but beyond that people have to
be better educated and realize that
thinking through problems and
understanding facts and creating better
arguments and responding to better
arguments and realizing when you're
wrong these are muscles that need to be
trained and there are certain
environments in which you can train them
well and there are certain environments
where they are guaranteed to atrophy
education largely consists in the former
and is training someone to interact with
ideas and with shared perceptions and
with arguments and evidence in a way
that is agnostic as to how things will
come out you're just curious to know
what's true you don't want to be wrong
you don't want to be self deceived you
don't want to have your epistemology
anchored to
wishful thinking and confirmation bias
and political partisanship and religious
taboos and other engines of [ __ ]
really I mean you want to be free of all
that and you don't want to have your
personal identity trimming down your
perception of what is true or likely to
be true or might yet happen people have
to understand what it feels like to be
willing to reason about the world in a
way that is unconcerned about the normal
psychological and tribal identity
formation that most people most of the
time used to filter against ideas
they'll hear an idea and they don't like
the sound of it because it violates some
cherished notion they already have in
the bag so they don't want to believe it
that should be a tip-off that's not more
evidence in favor of your worldview
that's evidence that you are an ape
who's disinclined to understand what's
actually happening in the world that
should be an alarm that goes off for you
not a reason to double down on the last
bad idea you just expressed on Twitter
yeah the way the the ego and concern for
reputation and personal identity and
shared human psychological biases
influence the way that we do
conversation seems to be a really big
hindrance here and being aware of how
your mind is reacting in each moment to
the kinetics of the conversation and
what is happening can be really skillful
for catching unwholesome or unskillful
reactions it seems and I found that
nonviolent communication has been really
helpful for me in terms of having
valuable open discourse where one's
identity your pride isn't on the line
the ability to seek truth with another
person instead of have a debate or
argument is a skill certainly developed
yet that kind of format for discussion
isn't always rewarded or promoted as
well as something like an adversarial
debate which tends to get a lot more
attention yeah
so as we begin to strengthen our
epistemology and conversational muscles
so that were able to arrive at agreement
on core issues that'll allow us to
create a better civilization and work on
what matters so I do want to pivot here
into what those specific things might be
now I have three general categories
maybe four for us to touch on here
the first is existential risk that
primarily come from technology which
might lead to the extinction of earth
originating life or more specifically
just the extinction of human life you
have a TED talk on a G iris that's
artificial general intelligence risk the
risk of machines becoming as smart or
smarter than human beings and being
misaligned with human values
there's also synthetic bio risk where
advancements in genetic engineering may
unleash new age of engineered pandemics
which are more lethal than anything that
is produced by nature we have nuclear
war and we also have new technologies or
events that might come about that we
aren't aware of or can't predict yet and
the other categories in terms of global
priorities I want to touch on our global
poverty animal suffering and human
health and longevity so how is it that
you think of and prioritize and what is
your reaction to these issues and their
relative importance in the world
well I'm persuaded that thinking about
existential risk is something we should
do much more it is amazing how few
people spend time on this problem it's a
big deal that we have the survival of
our species as a blind spot but I'm more
concerned about what seems likely or to
me which is not that we will do
something so catastrophic aliy unwise as
to erase ourselves certainly not in the
near term and we're capable of doing
that clearly but I think it's more
likely we're capable of ensuring our
unrecoverable misery for a good long
while we could just make life basically
not worth living but we'll be forced or
someone will be forced to live it all
the while basically a road
you're like hellscape could await us as
opposed to just pure annihilation
so that's a civilizational risk that I
worry more about than extinction because
it just seems probabilistically much
more likely to happen no matter how big
our errors are but I worry about our
stumbling into an accidental nuclear war
that's something that I think is still
pretty high on the list of likely ways
we could completely screw up the
possibility of human happiness in the
near term it's humbling to consider what
an opportunity cost this compared to as
possible minor pandemic is right I mean
we've got this pandemic that has locked
down most of humanity and every problem
we had and every risk we were running as
a species prior to anyone learning the
name of this virus is still here the
threat of nuclear war has not gone away
it's just this has taken up all of our
bandwidth we can't think about much else
it's also humbling to observe how hard a
time we're having even agreeing about
what's happening here much less
responding intelligently to the problem
if you imagine a pandemic that was
orders of magnitude more deadly and more
transmissible man this is pretty
startling dress rehearsal you know I
hope we learn something from this I hope
we think more about things like this
happening in the future and prepare for
them in advance when the fact that we
have a CDC they still cannot get its act
together it's just astounding
and again politics is the thing that is
coming up the gears in any machine that
would otherwise run halfway decently at
the moment we have a truly deranged
president and that is not a partisan
observation that is something that can
be said about Trump and it would not be
said about most other Republican
presidents there's nothing I would say
about Trump that I could say about
someone like Mitt Romney or any other
prominent Republican this is the perfect
circumstance to accentuate the downside
of having someone in charge who lies
more readily than any person in human
history perhaps it's like toxic waste at
the informational level has been spread
around
for three years now and now it really
matters that we have an information
ecosystem that has no immunity against
crazy distortions of the truth so I hope
we learned something from this and I
hope we begin to prioritize the list of
our gravest concerns and begin stealing
our civilization against the risk that
any of these things will happen and some
of these things are guaranteed to happen
the thing that's so bizarre about or
failure to grapple with a pandemic of
this sort is this is the one thing we
knew was going to happen this was not a
matter of if this was only a matter of
when now nuclear war is still a matter
of if right I mean we have the bombs
there on hair-trigger overseen by
absolutely bizarre and archaic protocols
and highly outdated technology we know
this is just a doomsday system we've
built that could go off at any time
through sheer accident or an aptitude
but it's not guaranteed to go off but
pandemics are just guaranteed to emerge
and we still were caught flat-footed
here and so I just think we need to use
this occasion to learn a lot about how
to respond to this sort of thing and
again if we can't convince the public
that this sort of thing is worth paying
attention to we have to do it behind
closed doors right I mean we have to get
people into power who have their heads
screwed on straight here and just Ram it
through there has to be a kind of
Manhattan Project level urgency to this
because this is about as benign a
pandemic as we could have had that would
still cause significant problems an
engineered virus you know weaponized
virus that was calculated to kill the
maximum number of people a minutes a
zombie movie all of a sudden and we're
not ready for the zombies I think that
my two biggest updates from the pandemic
were that human civilization is much
more fragile than I thought it was and
also I trust the US government way less
now in its capability to mitigate these
things I think at one point you said
that 9/11 was the first time that you
felt like you were actually in history
hmm who's 25 being in the cove
pandemic this is the first time that I
feel like I'm in human history because
my life so far has been very normal and
constrained and the boundaries between
everything have been very rigid and
solid but this is perturbing that
so you mentioned that you were slightly
less worried about humanity just erasing
ourselves do you have some kind of
existential risk and part of the idea
here seems to be that there are futures
that are not worth living like if
there's such thing as a moment or a day
that isn't worth living then there are
also futures that are not worth living
so I'm curious if you could unpack why
you feel that these periods of time that
are not worth living or more likely than
existential risks and if you think that
some of those existential conditions
could be permanent in terms of the
probability is it just seems obvious
that it is harder to eradicate the
possibility of human life entirely than
it is to just kill a lot of people and
make the remaining people miserable
right if a pandemic spreads whether its
natural or engineered that has seventy
percent mortality and the
transmissibility of measles that's going
to kill billions of people but it seems
likely that it may spare some millions
of people or tens of millions of people
even hundreds of millions of people and
those people will be left to suffer
their inability to function in the style
to which we've all grown accustomed so
it would be with war I mean we could
have a nuclear war and even a nuclear
winter but the idea that it'll kill
every last person or every last mammal
you would have to be a bigger war in a
worse winter to do that so I see the
prospect of things going horribly wrong
to be one that yields not a dial tone
but some level of remaining even
civilized life that's just terrible
that nobody would want where we
basically all have the quality of life
of what it was like on a mediocre day in
the middle of a civil war in Syria who
wants to live that way if every city on
earth is basically a dystopian cell on a
prison planet that for me is a
sufficient ruination of the hopes and
aspirations of civilized humanity that's
enough to motivate all of our efforts
to avoid things like accidental nuclear
war and uncontrolled pandemics and all
the rest and in some ways it's more of
motivating because when you ask people
what's the problem
with the failure to continue the species
right like if we all died painlessly in
our sleep tonight what's the problem
with that that actually stumps some
considerable number of people because
they immediately see that the complete
annihilation of species painlessly is
really a kind of victimless crime
there's no one around to suffer our
absence there's no one around to be
bereaved there's no one around to think
oh man we could have had billions of
years of creativity and insight and
exploration of the cosmos and now the
lights have gone out on the whole human
project there's no one around to suffer
that disillusionment so what's the
problem I'm persuaded that that's not
the perfect place to stand to evaluate
the ethics I agree that losing that
opportunity is a negative outcome that
we want to value appropriately but it's
harder to value it emotionally and it's
not as clear and it's also there's an
asymmetry between happiness and
suffering which i think is hard to get
around we are perhaps rightly more
concerned about suffering than we are
about losing opportunities for
well-being if I told you you could have
an hour of the greatest possible
happiness but it would have to be
followed by an hour of the worst
possible suffering I think most people
given that offer would say oh well okay
I'm good I'll just stick with what it's
like to be me the hour of the worst
possible misery seems like it's gonna be
worse than the highest possible
happiness is going to be good and I do
sort of share that intuition and when
you think about it in terms of the
future of humanity I think it is more
motivating to think not that your
grandchildren might not exist but that
your grandchildren might live horrible
lives really unendurable lives and
they'll be forced to live them because
they'll be born if for no other reason
then we have to persuade some people to
take these concerns seriously I think
that's the place to put most of the
emphasis
I think that's an excellent point I
think it makes it more morally salient
and leverages human self-interest more
one distinction that I want to make is
the distinction between existential
risks and global catastrophic risks
global catastrophic risks are those
which would kill a large fraction of
humanity without killing everyone and
existential risks are ones which would
exterminate all people are all earth
originating intelligent life and this
former risk the global catastrophic
risks are the ones which you're
primarily discussing here where
something goes really bad and now we're
left with some pretty bad existential
situation yeah
now we're not locked in that forever so
it's pretty far away from being what is
talked about in the effective altruism
community as a suffering risk that
actually might only last a hundred or a
few hundred years or maybe less who
knows it depends on what happened but
now taking a bird's-eye view again on
global priorities and standing on a
solid ground of ethics what is your
perspective on long term missed
philosophy this is the position or idea
the the deep future has overwhelming
moral priority given the countless
trillions of lives that could be lived
so if an existential risk occurs then
we're basically canceling the whole
future like you mentioned there won't be
any suffering and there won't be any joy
but we're missing out on a ton of good
it would seem and with the continued
evolution of life through genetic
engineering and enhancements and
artificial intelligence it would seem
that the future could also be
unimaginably good if you do an expected
value calculation about existential
risks you can estimate very roughly the
likelihood of each existential risk
whether it be from artificial general
intelligence or synthetic bio or nuclear
weapons or a Black Swan event that we
couldn't predict and you multiply that
by the amount of value in the future
you'll get some astronomical number
given the astronomical amount of value
in the future does this kind of argument
or viewpoint do the work for you to
commit you to seeing existential risk as
a global prior
or the central global priority well it
doesn't do the emotional work largely
because we're just bad at thinking about
long-term risk it doesn't even have to
be that long-term our intuitions and
concerns to degrade irrationally and
we're bad at thinking about the
well-being even of our future selves as
you get further out in time the term of
jargon is that we've hyperbolically
discount our future well-being so people
will smoke cigarettes or make other
improvement decisions in the present and
they know they will be the inheritors of
these bad decisions but some short-term
upside the mere pleasure of the next
cigarette say that convinces them that
they don't really have to think long and
hard about what their future self will
wish they had done at this point our
ability to be motivated by what we think
is likely to happen in the future is
even worse when we're thinking about our
descendants right and people we either
haven't met yet or may never meet I have
kids but I don't have grandkids right so
how much of my bandwidth has taken up
thinking about the kinds of lives my
grandchildren will have really none it's
conserved its safeguarded by my concern
about my kids at this point but then
there are people who don't have kids and
are just thinking about themselves so
it's hard to think about the
comparatively near future even a future
that are in some real mishap you have
every expectation of having to live in
yourself it's just hard to prioritize so
when you're talking about the far future
it becomes very very difficult and you
just have to have the science fiction
geek gene or something
disproportionately active in your brain
to really care about that unless you
think you are somehow going to cheat
death and get aboard the starship when
it's finally built you're popping 200
vitamins a day with Ray Kurzweil and you
think you might just be in the cohort of
people who are gonna make it out of here
without dying because we're just on the
cusp of engineering death out of the
system you know then I can see okay that
there's a self-interested
view of it but if you're really talking
about hypothetical people who you know
you will never come in contact with I
think
it's hard to be sufficiently motivated
even if you believe the moral algebra
here it's not clear to me that it need
run through I mean I agree with you that
if you do a basic expected value
calculation here and you start talking
about trillions of possible lives their
interest must outweigh the interests of
the seven-point eight or whatever it is
billion of us currently alive but a few
asymmetries here again the asymmetry
between actual and hypothetical lives
there are no identifiable lives who
would be deprived of anything if we all
just decided to stop having kids right
you have to take the point of view of
the people alive who make this decision
if we all just decided and listen these
are our lives to live we can decide how
we want to live them none of us want to
have kids anymore if we all
independently made that decision the
consequence on this calculus is we are
the worst people morally speaking who
have ever lived that doesn't quite
capture the moment or the experience or
the intentions and because we could do
this thing without ever thinking about
the implications of existential risk if
we didn't have a phrase for this and we
didn't have people like ourselves
talking about this is a problem people
could just be taken in by the
overpopulation thesis that that's really
the thing that is destroying the world
and what we need is some kind of guy in
reset where the earth reboots without us
so let's just stop having kids and let
nature reclaim the edges of the cities
you could see a kind of utopian
environmentalism creating some dogma
around that where it was no one's
intention ever to create some kind of
horrific crime and yet on this
existential risk calculus that's what
would have happened and so it's kind of
hard to think about the morality there
when you talk about people deciding not
to have kids and it would be the same
catastrophic outcome that situation to
me seems to be like looking over the
possible moral landscape and seeing a
mountain or not seeing a mountain but
there still being a mountain and then
you can have whatever kinds of
intentions you want but you're still
missing it and so from a purely
consequentialist
framework on this I feel not so bad
saying that this is probably one of the
worst things that have ever happened the
asymmetry here between suffering and
happiness still seems psychologically
relevant I mean it's not quite the worst
thing that's ever happened but the best
things that might have happened have
been canceled granted I think there's a
place to stand where you could think
that is a horrible outcome but again
it's not the same thing as creating some
hell and populated it I see what you're
saying I'm not sure that I quite share
the intuition about the asymmetry
between suffering and well-being I feel
somewhat suspect about that but that
would be like a huge tangent right now I
think now one of the crucial things that
you said was for those that are not
really compelled to care about the
long-term future argument if you don't
have the science fiction geek gene and
are not compelled by moral philosophy
the central way it seems to be that
you're able to compel people to care
about global catastrophic and
existential risk is to demonstrate how
they're very likely within the century
and so their direct descendants like
their children or grandchildren or even
them may live in a world that is very
bad or they may die in some kind of a
global catastrophe which is terrifying
do you see this as the primary way of
leveraging human self-interest and
feelings and emotions to make
existential and global catastrophic
risks salient and pertinent for the
masses it's certainly half the story and
it might be the most compelling half I'm
not saying that we should be just
worried about the downside because the
upside also is something we should
celebrate and aim for the other side of
the story is that we've made incredible
progress and we take someone like Steven
Pinker and his big books of what is
often perceived as happy talk I mean
he's pointing out all of the progress
morally and technologically and at the
level of Public Health and it's just
been virtually nothing but progress
there's no point in history where you're
luckier to live then in the present so
that's true I think that the thing that
Steve's story conceals or at least
doesn't spend enough time acknowledging
is that the risk of things going
terribly wrong is also increasing it was
also true 100
ago that it would have been impossible
for one person or a small band of people
to ruin life for everyone else and now
that's actually possible okay just
imagine if this current pandemic we're
an engineered virus more like a lethal
form of measles you might take five
people to create that and release it and
here we would be locked down in a truly
terrifying circumstance so the risk is
ramped up so I think we just have to
talk about both signs of it it's just
there's no limit to how beautiful life
could get if we get our act together
take an argument of the sort that David
Deutsch makes about the power of
knowledge every problem has a solution
born of a sufficient insight into how
things work ie knowledge unless the laws
of physics rules it out so if it's
compatible the laws of physics knowledge
can solve the problem that's virtually a
blank check with reality that we could
live to cash if we don't kill ourselves
in the process but again as the upside
becomes more and more obvious the risk
that we're going to do something
catastrophic aliy stupid is also
increasing and the principles here are
the same the only reason why we're
talking about existential risk is
because we have made so much progress
without the progress there'd be no way
to make a sufficiently large mistake it
really has two sides of the coin of
increasing knowledge and technical power
one thing that I wanted to throw in here
in terms of the kinetics of long term
ism and emotional salience II it would
be stupidly optimistic I think to think
that everyone could become selfless
Bodhisattvas but in terms of your
interest and the way in which you
promote meditation and mindfulness and
your arguments against the conventional
experiential and conceptual notion of
the self for me at least has dissolved
much of the barriers which would hold me
from being emotionally motivated from
long-term ism now that itself I think is
another long conversation but when your
sense of self is becoming nudged and
disentangled and dissolved in new ways
the idea
the it won't be you in the future or the
idea that the beautiful dreams that
dyson sphere's will be having in a
billion years are not you that begins to
relax a bit but that's probably not
something that is helpful for most
people but I do think that it's possible
for people to adopt and for meditation
and mindfulness and introspection to
lead to this weakening of sense of self
which then also opens one's optimism and
compassion and mind towards the
long-term is fear yeah well it's
something that you get from reading
Derek Parfit work the paradoxes of
identity that he so brilliantly framed
and tried to reason through yield
something like what you're talking about
it's not so important whether it's you
because this notion of you is in fact
paradoxical to the point of being
impossible to pin down whether the you
that woke up in your bed this morning is
the same person who went to sleep in it
the night before that is problematic
right and yet there's this fact of some
degree of psychological continuity the
basic fact experientially is just there
is consciousness and its contents the
only place for feelings and perceptions
and moods and expectations and
experience to show up is in
consciousness whatever it is and
whatever its connection to the physics
of things actually turns out to be
there's just consciousness and the
question of where it appears is
genuinely interesting one
philosophically and intellectually and
scientifically and ultimately morally
because you know if we build conscious
robots or conscious computers and build
them in a way that causes them to suffer
well we've just done something terrible
well we might do that inadvertently if
we don't know how consciousness arises
based on information processing or
whether it does so it's all interesting
terrain to think about but if the lights
are still on a billion years from now
and the view of the universe is
unimaginably bright and interesting and
beautiful and all kinds of creative
things are possible by virtue of the
kinds of minds involved that will be
much better than any alternative that's
certainly how it seems to me yeah I
agree
some things here that ring true seem to
be you always talk about how there is
only consciousness and its contents I
really like the phrase seeing from
nowhere that usually is quite motivating
for me in terms of the arguments against
the conventional conceptual and
experiential notions of self there just
seems to be against an Shi ations of
consciousness intrinsically free of
identity two things to distinguish here
because there's the philosophical
conceptual side of the conversation
which can show you that things like your
concept of a self or certainly your
concept of a itself that could have free
will that that doesn't make a lot of
sense it doesn't make sense when mapped
on to physics it doesn't make sense when
looked for neurologically anyway you
look at it it begins to fall apart and
that's interesting but again it doesn't
necessarily change anyone's experience
it's just a riddle that can't be solved
but then there's the experiential side
which you encounter more and things like
meditation or psychedelics or sheer good
luck where you can experience
consciousness without the sense that
there's a subject or a self in the
center of it appropriating experiences
just a continuum of experience that
doesn't have structure in the normal way
and what's more that's not a problem and
in fact it's the solution to many
problems right a lot of the discomfort
you have felt psychologically goes away
when you punch through to a recognition
that consciousness is just the space in
which thoughts and sensations and
emotions continually appear and change
and vanish and if there's no thinker
authoring the thoughts and there's no
experience or in the middle of the
experience and it's not to say you don't
have a body there's every sign that you
have a body is still appearing there's
sensations of tension and warmth and
pressure and movement their sights their
sounds but again everything is simply an
appearance in this condition which I'm
calling consciousness for lack of a
better word and there's no subject to
whom it all refers that can be immensely
freeing to recognize and that's a matter
of a direct change in one's experience
it's not a matter of banging your head
against the riddles of Derek Parfit or
any other way of undermining ones belief
in personal identity or the reification
of a self a little bit earlier we talked
a little bit about the other side of the
existential risk coin now the other side
of that is this existential Hope we like
to call at the future of life Institute
we're not just like a doom and gloom
Society it's also about how the future
can be unimaginably good if we can get
our act together and apply the
appropriate wisdom to manage and Stuart
our technologies with wisdom and
benevolence in mind pivoting in here and
reflecting a little bit on the
implications of some of this no self
conversation we've been having for
global priorities the effect of altruism
community has sort of narrowed down on
three of these global priorities as
central issues of consideration
existential risk global poverty and
animal suffering we talk to a bunch
about existential risk already global
poverty is prolific and many of us live
in quite nice and abundant circumstances
and then there's animal suffering which
can be thought of is in two categories
one of being factory farmed animals
where we have billions upon billions of
animals being born into miserable
conditions and being slaughtered for
sustenance and then we also have wild
animal suffering which is a bit more
esoteric and seems like it's harder to
get any traction on helping to alleviate
thinking about these last two points
global poverty and animal suffering what
is your perspective on these I find the
lack of willingness for people to
empathize and be compassionate towards
animal suffering to be quite frustrating
as well as global poverty of course and
if you view the perspective of no self
as potentially being informative or
helpful for leveraging human compassion
motivation to help other people and to
help animals
one quick argument here that comes from
the conventional view of self so isn't
strictly true irrational but is
motivating for me is that I feel like I
was just born
me and then I just woke up one day is
Lucas I referring to this conventional
and experiential illusory notion that I
have of myself this convenient fiction
that I have now you're going to die and
you could wake up as a factory farmed
animal and surely there are those
billions upon billions of instantiations
of consciousness that are just going
through misery and if the self is an
illusion then there are selfless chicken
and cow experiences of enduring
suffering so any thoughts or reactions
you have to global poverty animal
suffering and what I've mentioned here I
guess the first thing to observe is that
again we are badly set up to prioritize
what should be prioritized and to have
the emotional response commensurate with
what we could rationally understand is
so we have a problem of motivation we
have a problem of making data real this
has been psychologically studied but
it's just manifest in oneself and in the
world we care more about the salient
narrative that has a single protagonist
than we do about the data on even human
suffering the classic example here is
one little girl falls down a well and
you get wall-to-wall news coverage and
all the while there could be a genocide
or a famine killing hundreds of
thousands of people and it doesn't merit
more than five minutes you know one
broadcast that's clearly a bug not a
feature morally speaking but it's
something we have to figure out how to
work with because I don't think it's
going away one of the things that the
effect of altruism philosophy has done I
think usefully is that it is separated
two projects which up until the
emergence of effective altruism I think
we're more or less always conflated
they're both valid projects but one has
much greater moral consequence the
fusion of the two is the concern about
giving and how it makes one feel I want
to feel good about being philanthropic
and therefore I want to give to causes
that give me these good feels and in
fact at the end of the day the feeling I
get from giving is what motivates me to
give and
so if I'm given in a way that doesn't
really produce that feeling well then
I'm gonna give less or give less
reliably even in a contemplative
Buddhist context there's an explicit
fusion of these two things the reason to
be moral and to be generous is not
merely or even principally the effect on
the world the reason is because it makes
you a better person it gives you a
better mind do you feel better in your
own skin it is in fact more rewarding
than being selfish I think that's true
but that doesn't get at really the
important point here which is we're
living in a world where the difference
between having good and bad luck is so
enormous the inequalities are so
shocking and indefensible the fact that
I was born me and not born in some
hellhole in the middle of a civil war
soon to be orphaned and impoverished and
riddled by disease I mean I can take no
responsibility for the difference in
luck there and that difference is the
difference that matters more than
anything else in my life right what the
effective altruists
community has prioritized is actually
helping the most people are in the most
sentient beings and that is fully
divorce' below makes you feel now I
think it shouldn't be ultimately
divorce' Balai think we should
recalibrate our feelings or struggle to
so that we do find doing the most good
the most rewarding thing in the end but
it's hard to do and my inability to do
it personally is something that I have
just consciously corrected for I've
talked about this a few times on my
podcast but when will McCaskill came on
my podcast and we spoke about these
things you know I was convinced at the
end of the day well I should take this
seriously and I recognize that fighting
malaria by sending bed nets to people in
sub-saharan Africa is not a cause I find
particularly sexy I don't find it that
emotionally engaging I don't find it
that rewarding to picture the outcome I
make again compared to other possible
ways of intervening and
in misery and producing some better
outcome it's not the same thing as
rescuing the little girl from the well
and yet I was convinced that you know as
will said on that podcast and as
organizations like give well a test
giving money to the against malaria
foundation was and remains one of the
absolute best uses of every dollar to
mitigate unnecessary death and suffering
so I just decided to automate my giving
to the against malaria foundation
because I knew I couldn't be trusted to
wake up every day or every month or
every quarter or whatever it would be
and recommit to that project because
some other project would have captured
my attention in the meantime and I was
either gonna give less to it or not give
it all in the end and so I'm convinced
that we do have to get around ourselves
and figure out how to prioritize what a
rational analysis says we should
prioritize and get the sentimentality
out of it in general but it's very hard
to escape entirely and I think we do
need to figure out creative ways to
reformat our sense of reward the reward
we find in helping people has to begin
to become more closely coupled to what
is actually most helpful and conversely
the disgust or horror we feel over bad
outcomes should be more closely coupled
to the worst things that happen as
opposed to just the most shocking but at
the end of the day minor things I mean
we're just much more captivated by a
sufficiently ghastly story involving
three people than we are by the deaths
of literally millions that happen some
other way
these are bugs we have to figure out how
to correct for yeah I hear you the
person running in the burning building
to save the child as a song as a hero
but if you are say earning to give for
example and right enough checks to save
dozens of lives over your lifetime that
might not go recognized or felt in the
same one and also it's these are
different people too and it's also true
to say that someone who is
psychologically and interpersonally not
that and spawn
you know and certainly not a saint might
wind up doing more good than any saint
ever does or could I don't happen to
know Bill Gates he could be Saint like
and I literally never met him but I
don't get that sense that he is right I
think he's kind of a normal technologist
and might be normally egocentric and
concerned about his reputation and
legacy and he might be a prickly bastard
behind closed doors you know I don't
know but he certainly stands a chance of
doing more good than any person in human
history at this point just based on the
checks he's writing and his intelligent
prioritization of his philanthropic
efforts so there is an interesting
uncoupling here where you could just
imagine someone who might be a total
[ __ ] but actually does more good than
any army of saints you could muster and
that's interesting that just proves the
point that a concern about real-world
outcomes is divorce' beliee psychology
that we tend to associate with doing
good in the world and on the point of
animal suffering I share your intuitions
there although again this is a little
bit like climate change and that I think
that the ultimate fix will be
technological it'll be a matter of
people producing the impossible burger
squared that is just so good that you
know no one's tempted to eat a normal
burger anymore or something like Memphis
meats which actually I invested in I
have no idea where it's going as a
company but when I had its CEO on my
podcasts back in the day uma Follette II
I just thought this is fantastic to
engineer actual meat without producing
any animal suffering I hope he can bring
this to scale at the time it was like an
$18,000 meatball I don't know what it is
now but it's that kind of thing that
will close the door to the
slaughterhouse more than just convincing
billions of people about the ethics it's
too difficult and the truth may be not
aligned with exactly what we want I'm
gonna reap the whirlwind of criticism
from the vegan mafia here but it's just
not clear to me that it's easy to be a
healthy vegan forget about yourself as
an adult making a choice to be a vegan
raising vegan kids is a medical
experiment on your kids of a certain
sort
and it's definitely possible to screw it
up there's just no question about that
if you're not going to admit that you're
not a responsible parent it is possible
it is by no means easier to raise
healthy vegan kids than it is to raise
kids who eat meat sometimes and that's
just a problem right so that's a problem
that has a technical solution but
there's still diversity of opinion about
what constitutes a healthy human diet
even when all things are on the menu and
so we're just not there yet and it's
unlikely to be just a matter of
supplementing b12 and then the final
point you made does get us into a kind
of I would argue a reductio ad absurdum
of the whole project
ethically when you're talking about
losing sleep over whether to protect the
rabbits from the foxes out there in the
wild if you're gonna go down that path
and I will grant you it wouldn't want to
trade places with a rabbit and there's a
lot of suffering out there in the
natural world but if you're going to try
to figure out how to minimize the
suffering of wild animals in relation to
other wild animals then I think you are
kind of anti-natal list with respect to
the natural world and then it would be
just better if these animals didn't
exist right let's just hit stop on the
whole biosphere if that's the project
then there's the argument that there are
many more ways to suffer than to be
happy as a sentient being and you know
whatever story you want to tell yourself
about the promise of future humanity
it's just so awful to be a rabbit or an
insect that if an asteroid hit us and
cancelled everything that would be a net
positive yeah that's an actual review
that I hear around a bunch and I guess
my quick response is as we move farther
into the future if we're able to reach
an existential situation which is secure
and where there is flourishing and we're
trying to navigate the moral landscape
to new Peaks it seems like we will have
to do something about wild animal
suffering with AGI and align
superintelligence I'm sure there could
be very creative solutions using genetic
engineering or something our descendants
will have to figure that out whether
they are just like our wild spaces
really nests
in the future and our wild animal is
actually necessary or are we just going
to use those resources in space to build
more AI that would dream beautiful
dreams I just think it may be in fact
the case that nature is just a horror
show it is bad almost any place you
could be born in the natural world
you're unlucky to be a rabbit and you're
unlucky to be a fox we're lucky to be
humans sort of and we can dimly imagine
how much luckier we might get in the
future if we don't screw up
I find it compelling to imagine that we
could create a world where certainly
most human lives are well worth living
and better than most human lives ever
were
again I follow Pinker in feeling that
we've sort of done that already it's not
to say that there aren't profoundly
unlucky people in this world and it's
not to say that things couldn't change
in a minute for all of us but life has
gotten better and better for virtually
everyone when you compare us to any
point in the past if we get to the place
you're imagining where we have AGI that
we have managed to align with our
interests and we're migrating into
spaces of experience that changes
everything it's quite possible we will
look back on the quote natural world and
be totally unsentimental about it which
is to say we could compassionately make
the decision to either switch it off or
no longer provide for its continuation
say that's there's a bad software
program that evolution designed and
wolves and rabbits and bears and mice
they were all unlucky on some level we
could be wrong about that or we might
discover something else we might
discover that intelligence is not all
it's cracked up to be that it's just
this perturbation on something that's
far more rewarding and at the center of
the moral landscape there's a peak
higher than any other and it's not one
that's elaborated by lots of ideas and
lots of creativity and lots of
distinctions it's just this great well
of bliss that we actually want to fully
merge with
and we might find out that the cicada is
were already there
you know I'm who knows how weird this
place is yeah that makes sense I totally
agree with you and I feel this is true I
also feel that there's some price that
is paid because there's already some
stigma around even thinking this I think
it's a really early idea to have in
terms of the history of human
civilization and so people's initial
reaction is like god what nature is so
beautiful and why would you do that to
the animals etc we may come to find out
that nature is just very negative but I
could be wrong and maybe it would be
around neutral or better than that but
that would require a more robust in
advance signs of consciousness so just
hitting on this next one fairly quickly
effective altruism is interested in
finding new global priorities and causes
they call this cause X so something that
may be a subset of existential risk or
something other than existential risk or
global poverty or animal suffering
probably still just has to do with the
suffering of sentient beings so do you
think that a possible candidate for
cause x would be machine suffering or
the suffering of other non-human
conscious things that were completely
unaware of yeah well I think it's a
totally valid concern again it's one of
these concerns it's hard to get your
moral intuitions tuned up to respond to
people have a default intuition that a
conscious machine is impossible that
substrate independence on some level is
impossible they're making an assumption
without ever doing it explicitly in fact
I think most people would explicitly
deny this but it is implicit in what
they then go on to think when you pose
the question of the possibility of
suffering machines and suffering
computers that just seems like something
that never needs to be worried about and
yet the only way to close the door to
worrying about it is to assume that
consciousness is totally substrate
dependent you know that we would never
build a machine that could suffer
because we're building machines out of
some other material if we built a
machine out of biological neurons well
then then we might be up for
condemnation morally because we've taken
an intolerable risk analogous to
creating
you know some human chimp hybrid or
whatever is that obviously that thing's
gonna suffer it's an ape of some sort
and now it's in a lab and what sort of
monster would do that right and would
expect the lights to come on in a system
of that sort but if consciousness is the
result of information processing on some
level and again that's an if we're not
sure that's the case and if information
processing is truly substrate
independent and that seems like more
than an if at this point we sort of know
that's true then we could inadvertently
build conscious machines and then the
question is you know what is it like to
be those machines and are they suffering
there's no way to prevent that on some
level and certainly if there's any
relationship between consciousness and
intelligence
if building more and more intelligent
machines is synonymous with increasing
the likelihood that the lights will come
on experientially well then we're
clearly on that path and so it's totally
worth worrying about but it's again
judging from what my own mind is like
and what my conversations with other
people suggest it seems very hard to
care about for people and that's just
another one of these wrinkles yeah I
think a good way of framing this is that
humanity has a history of committing
moral catastrophes because of bad
incentives and they don't even realize
how bad the thing is that they're doing
or they just don't really care they
rationalize it like subjugation of women
and slavery we're in the context of
human history and we look back at these
people and see them as morally abhorrent
now the question is what is it today
that we're doing that's morally
abhorrent well I think factory farming
is easily one contender and perhaps
human selfishness that leads to global
poverty and millions of people drowning
in shallow ponds is another one that
we'll look back on so with just some
foresight towards the future I agree
that machine suffering is intuitively
and emotionally difficult to empathize
with if your sci-fi gene isn't turned on
and it could be the next thing yeah so
I'd also like to pivot here into AI
alignment and AGI in terms of
existential risk from a GI or
transformative AI systems do you have
thoughts on public intellectuals who are
skeptic
of existential risk from a GI or
superintelligence you had a talk about
AI risk and I believe you got some flack
from AI community about that Elon Musk
was just skirmishing with the head of AI
at Facebook I think so what is your
perspective about the disagreement and
confusion here it comes down to a kind
of failure of imagination on the one
hand and also just bad argumentation no
sane person who's concerned about this
is concerned because they think it's
gonna happen this year or next year it's
not a bet on how soon this is going to
happen then for me it certainly isn't
the bet on how soon it's gonna happen so
it's just a matter of the implications
of continually making progress in
building more and more intelligent
machines any progress doesn't have to be
Moore's law it just has to be continued
progress will ultimately deliver us into
relationship with something more
intelligent than ourselves and to think
that that is far-fetched or is not
likely to happen or can't happen is to
assume some things that we just can't
assume it is to assume that substrate
independence is not in the cards for
intelligence forget about consciousness
what consciousness is or thuggin alter
this question I'm not suggesting that AG
I need be conscious it just needs to be
more competent than we are so we already
know that our phones are more competent
as calculators than we are they're more
competent chess players than we are and
you just have to keep stacking cognitive
information processing abilities on that
and making progress
however incremental I don't see how
anyone can be assuming substrate
dependence for really any of the
features of our mind apart from perhaps
consciousness take the top 200 things we
do cognitively consciousness aside just
as a matter of sheer information
processing and behavioral control and
power to make decisions and you start
checking those off those have to be
substrate independent you know facial
recognition voice recognition we can
already do that
in silico it's just not something you
need meat to do so we're going to build
machines that get better and better at
all of these things and ultimately they
will pass the Turing test and ultimately
it will be like chess or now go as far
as the eye can see what will be in
relationship to something that is better
than we are at everything that we have
prioritized every human competence we
have put enough priority in that we took
the time to build it into our machines
in the first place
theorem proving in mathematics
engineering software programs there is
no reason why a computer will ultimately
not be the best programmer in the end
again unless you're assuming that
there's something magical about doing
this in meat and I don't know anyone
who's assuming that so arguing about the
time horizon is a non sequitur right no
one is saying that this need happened
soon to ultimately be worth thinking
about and we know that whatever the time
horizon is it can happen suddenly we
have historically been very bad at
predicting when there will be a
breakthrough and this is a point that
Stuart Russell makes all the time
if you look at what Rutherford said
about the nuclear chain reaction being a
pipe dream
it wasn't even 24 hours before Leo
Szilard committed the chain reaction to
paper and had the relevant breakthrough
so we know we can make bad estimates
about the time horizon so it at some
point we could be ambushed by a real
breakthrough which suddenly delivers
exponential growth in intelligence and
then there's a question of how quickly
that that could unfold and whether
there's something like an intelligence
explosion that's possible we can't know
for sure but you need to find some
foothold to doubt whether these things
are possible and the footholds that
people tend to reach for are either
non-existent or they're non sequiturs
again the time horizon is irrelevant and
yet the time horizon is the first thing
you hear from people who are skeptics
about this if it's not gonna happen for
a very long time well it miss Stuart
Russell's point here which is again it's
just a reframing but in the persuasion
business reframing is everything the
people
are consoled by this idea that this it's
not gonna happen for 50 years wouldn't
be so consoled if we receive a message
from an alien civilization which said
people of Earth we will arrive on your
humble planet in 50 years get ready if
that happened we would be prioritizing
our response to that moment differently
than the people who think it's gonna
take 50 years for us to build a GI are
prioritizing their response to what's
coming we would recognize a relationship
with something more powerful than
ourselves is in the offing and it's only
reasonable to do that on the assumption
that we will continue to make progress
the point I made in my TED talk is that
the only way to assume we're not going
to continue to make progress is to be
convinced of a very depressing thesis
the only way we wouldn't continue to
make progress is if we open the wrong
door of the sort that you and I have
been talking about in this conversation
if we invoke some really bad roll of the
dice in terms of existential risk or
catastrophic civilizational failure and
we just find ourselves unable to build
better and better computers I mean
that's the only thing that would cause
us to be unable to do that and given the
power and value of intelligent machines
we will build more and more intelligent
machines at almost any cost at this
point and so failure to do it would be a
sign that something truly awful has
happened yeah from my perspective the
people that are skeptical of substrate
independence I wouldn't say that those
are necessarily AI researchers those are
regular persons or lay persons who are
not computer scientists and I think
that's motivated by mind-body dualism
where one has a conventional and
experiential sense of the mind as being
non-physical which may be motivated by
popular religious beliefs but when we
get into the area of actual AI
researchers for them it seems to either
be like they're attacking some naive
version of the argument or a straw man
or something like robots becoming
spontaneously malevolent yeah so it's
either that or they think that the
alignment
problem isn't as hard as it is so they
have some intuition like why the hell
would we even release systems that
weren't safe like why would we not make
technology that served us or something
and so to me it seems that when there
are people from like the mainstream
machine learning community attacking AI
alignment and existential risk
considerations from AI it seems like
they just don't understand how hard the
alignment problem is well they're not
taking seriously the proposition that
what we will have built are truly
independent Minds more powerful than our
own if you actually drill down on what
that description means it doesn't mean
something that is perfectly enslaved by
us for all time and because that is by
definition something that couldn't be
more intelligent across the board than
we are the analogy I use is imagine if
dogs had invented us to protect their
interests well so far it seems to be
going really well we're clearly more
intelligent than dogs they have no idea
what we're doing or thinking about or
talking about most of the time and they
see us making elaborate sacrifices for
their well-being which we do I mean the
people who own dogs care a lot about
them and make you could argue irrational
sacrifices to make sure they're happy
and healthy but again back to the
pandemic if we recognize that we had a
pandemic that was going to kill the
better part of humanity and it was
jumping from dogs to people and the only
way to stop this is to kill all the dogs
we would kill all the dogs on a Thursday
there'd be some holdouts but they would
lose the dog project would be over and
the dogs would never understand what
happened that's because humans aren't
perfectly aligned with dog values but
that's the thing I mean maybe it's a
solvable problem but it's clearly not a
trivial problem because what we're
imagining our minds that continue to
grow in power and grow in ways that by
definition we can't anticipate like dogs
can't possibly anticipate where we will
go next what we will become interested
in next what we will discover next what
we'll prioritize next if you're not
imagining my
so vast that we can't capture their
contents ourselves you're not talking
about the AGI that the people who are
worried about alignment are talking
about maybe this is like a little bit of
a nuanced distinction between you or I
but I think the that story that you're
developing there seems to assume the the
utility function or the value learning
or the objective function of the systems
that we're trying to align with human
values is dynamic it may be the case
that you can build a really smart alien
mind and it might become super
intelligent but there are arguments that
maybe you could make its alignment
stable that's the thing we have to hope
for right I'm not a computer scientist
so as far as the do ability of this
that's something I don't have good
intuitions about but Stuart Russell's
argument that we would need a system
whose ultimate value is to more and more
closely approximate our current values
that would continually no matter how
much its intelligence escapes our own it
would continually remain available to
the conversation with us where we say oh
no no stop doing that that's not what we
want
that would be the most important message
from its point of view no matter how
vast its mind god
maybe that's doable right but that's the
kind of thing that would have to be true
for the thing to remain completely
aligned to us because the truth is we
don't want it aligned to who we used to
be and we don't want it aligned to the
values of the Taliban we want to grow in
moral wisdom as well and we want to be
able to revise our own ethical codes and
this thing that's smarter than us
presumably could help us do that
provided it doesn't just have its own
epiphanies which cancel the value of our
own or subvert our own in a way that we
didn't foresee if it really has our best
interests at heart
but our best interests are best
conserved by it deciding to pull the
plug on everything well then we might
not see the wisdom of that I mean it
might even be the right answer now this
is assuming it's conscious we could be
building something that is actually
morally more important than we are yeah
that makes sense
certainly eventually we would want it to
be aligned with some form of idealized
human values and idealized human meta
preferences over how value should change
and evolve into the deep future this is
known I think as ambitious value
learning and it is the hardest form of
value learning and maybe we can make
something safe without doing this level
of ambitious value learning but
something like that maybe deeper in the
future now as we've made moral progress
throughout history we've been expanding
our moral circle of consideration in
particular we've been doing this farther
into space deeper into time across
species and potentially soon across
substrates what do you see is the
central way of continuing to expand our
moral circle of consideration and
compassion well I just think we have to
recognize that things like distance in
time and space and superficial
characteristics like whether something
has a face much less a face they can
make appropriate expressions or a voice
that we can relate to none of these
things have moral significance the fact
that another person is far away from you
in space right now shouldn't
fundamentally affect how much you care
whether or not they're being tortured or
whether they're starving to death now it
does we know it does people are much
more concerned about what's happening on
their doorstep but I think proximity if
it has any weight at all it has less and
less weight the more our decisions
obviously affect people regardless of
separation in space but the more it
becomes truly easy to help someone on
another continent because you can just
push a button in your browser then
you're caring less about them is clearly
a bug and so it's just noticing that the
things that attenuate our compassion
tend to be things that for evolutionary
reasons we're designed to discount in
this way but at the level of you know
actual moral reasoning about a global
civilization it doesn't make any sense
and it prevents us from solving the
biggest problems pivoting into ethics
more so now I'm not sure if this is the
formal label that you use but your work
on the moral landscape lends you pretty
much
it seems in the moral realism category
mm-hmm you've said something like put
your hand in fire to know what bad is
that seems to disclose or seems to argue
about the self intimating nature of
suffering about how it's like clearly
bad if you don't believe me go and do
the suffering things from other moral
realists who I've talked to and have
argued for moral realism like Peter
Singer they make similar arguments what
view or theory of consciousness are you
most partial to and how does this inform
this perspective about the self
intimating nature of suffering as being
a bad thing well I'm a realist with
respect to morality and consciousness in
the sense that I think it's possible not
to know what you're missing so if you're
a realist the property that makes the
most sense to me is that there are facts
about the world that are facts whether
or not anyone knows them it's possible
for everyone to be wrong about something
we could all agree about X and be wrong
that's the realist position as opposed
to pragmatism or some other variant
where it's all just a matter it's all a
language game and the truth value of a
statement is just the measure of the
work it does in conversation so with
respect to consciousness you know a
realist in the sense that if a system is
conscious if a cricket is conscious if a
sea cucumber is conscious they're
conscious whether we know it or not for
the purposes of this conversation so
let's just decide that they're not
conscious right the lights are not on in
those systems well that's a claim that
we could believe we could all believe it
but we could be wrong about it and so
the facts exceed our experience at any
given moment and so it is with morally
salient facts like the existence of
suffering if a system can be conscious
whether I know it or not a system can be
suffering whether I know it or not and
that system could be me in the future or
in some counterfactual state I could
think I'm doing the right thing by doing
X but the truth is I would have been
much happier had I done Y and I'll never
know that I was just wrong about the
consequences of living in a certain way
that's what realism on my view entails
so the way this relates to questions of
morality and good and evil and right and
wrong this back to my analogy of the
moral landscape
I think morality really is a navigation
problem there are possibilities of
experience in this universe and we don't
even need the concept of morality we
don't need the concept of right and
wrong and good and evil really I mean
it's shorthand for in my view the way we
should talk about the burden that's on
us in each moment to figure out what we
should do next
where should we point ourselves across
this landscape of mind and possible
minds and knowing that it's possible to
move in the wrong direction and what
does it mean to be moving in the wrong
direction well it's moving in a
direction where everything is getting
worse and worse and everything that was
good a moment ago is breaking down to no
good end I mean you could conceive of
moving down a slope on the moral
landscape only to ascend some higher
peak I mean that's intelligible to me
that we might have to all move in the
direction that seems to be making things
worse but it is a sacrifice worth making
because it's the only way to get to
something more beautiful and more stable
I'm not saying that's the world we're
living in but it certainly seems like a
possible world but this just doesn't
seem open to doubt there's a range of
experience on offer and on the one end
it's horrific and painful and all the
misery is without any silver lining
right it's not like we learn a lot from
this ordeal no it just gets worse and
worse and worse and worse and then we
die and I call that the worst possible
misery for everyone right so the worst
possible misery for everyone is bad if
anything is bad if the word bad is going
to mean anything it has to apply to the
worst possible misery for everyone but
now some people come in and think
they're doing philosophy when they say
things like well who's to say the worst
possible misery for everyone is bad
or should we avoid the worst possible
misery for everyone can you prove that
we should avoid it and I actually think
those are unintelligible noises that
they're making
you can say those words I don't think
you can actually mean those words I have
no idea what that person actually thinks
they're saying you can play a language
game like that but when you actually
look at what the words mean the worst
possible misery for everyone to then say
well should we avoid it in a world where
you should do anything where the words
should make sense there's nothing that
you should do more than avoid the worst
possible misery for everyone by
definition I mean it's more fundamental
than the concept of should what I would
argue is if you're hung up on the
concept of should and you're taken in by
Humes
flippant and ultimately misleading
paragraph on you can't get a lot from it
is you don't need arts then there is
just this condition of is there's a
range of experience on offer and on the
one end it is horrible on the other end
it is unimaginably beautiful and we
clearly have a preference for one over
the other if we have a preference for
anything there is no preference more
fundamental than escaping the worst
possible misery for everyone if you
doubt that you're just not thinking
about how bad things can get it's
incredibly frustrating me in this
conversation you're hearing the legacy
of the frustration I felt in talking to
otherwise smart and well-educated people
who think they're on interesting
philosophical ground in doubting whether
we should avoid the worst possible
misery for everyone or that it would be
good to avoid it or perhaps it's
intelligible to have other priorities
and again I just think that they're not
understanding the words worst possible
misery and everyone not letting those
words and land in language cortex and if
they do they'll see that there is no
other place to stand where you could
have other priorities yeah my brief
reaction to that is I still honestly
feel confused about this so maybe I'm in
the camp of frustrating people I can
imagine other evolutionary timelines
where there are minds that just
for the worst possible misery for
everyone just because in mine space
those mines are physically possible well
that's possible we could certainly
create a paperclip Maximizer that is
just essentially designed to make every
conscious being and suffer as much as it
can and if that would be especially easy
to do provided that intelligence wasn't
conscious if it's not a matter of its
suffering then yeah we could use AGI to
make things awful for everyone else you
could create a sadistic AGI that wanted
everyone else to suffer and it derived
immense pleasure from that or immense
suffering like I don't see anything
intrinsically motivating about suffering
as navigating a mind necessarily away
from it computationally I can imagine a
mind just suffering as much as possible
and spreads that as much as possible and
that maybe the suffering is bad and some
objective sense given consciousness
realism and that that was disclosing the
intrinsic valence of consciousness in
the universe but is our distinction
there still seems confusing to me like
yes suffering is bad and like maybe the
worst possible misery for everyone is
bad but that's not universally
motivating for all possible Minds the
usual problem here is it's easy for me
to care about my own suffering but why
should I care about the suffering of
others that seems to be the ethical
stalemate that people worry about my
response there is that it doesn't matter
maybe you can take the view from above
there and you can just say the universe
would be better if all the sentient
beings suffered less and it would be
worse if they suffered more and if
you're unconvinced by that you just have
to keep turning the dial to separate
those two more and more and more and
more so that you get to the extremes if
any given sentient being can't be moved
to care about the experience of others
well that's one sort of world right
that's not a peak on the moral landscape
that will be a world where beings are
more callous
than they would otherwise be in some
other corner of the universe and they'll
bump into each other more and they'll be
more conflict and they'll fail to
cooperate in certain ways that would
have opened doors to positive
experiences
they now can't have and you can try to
use moralizing language about all this
and say well you still can't convince me
that I should care about people starving
to death in Somalia but the reality is
an inability to care about that has
predictable consequences if enough
people can't care about that then
certain things become impossible and
those things if they were possible lead
to good outcomes that if you had a
different sort of mind you would enjoy
so all of this bites its own tail in an
interesting way when you imagine being
able to change a person's moral
intuitions and the question is well
should you change those intuitions would
it be good to change your sense of what
is good that question has an answer on
the moral landscape it has an answer
when viewed a navigation problem right
but isn't the assumption there that if
something leads to a good world then you
should do it yes you can even drop your
notion of should it's just there's a I'm
sure it's finite but a functionally
infinite number of worlds on offer and
there's ways to navigate into those
spaces and there ways to fail to
navigate into those spaces there ways to
try and fail and worse still there ways
to not know what you're missing to not
even know where you should be pointed on
this landscape which is to say you need
to be a realist here there are
experiences that are better than any
experience that you are going to have
and you are never going to know about
them possible experiences and granting
that you don't need a concept of should
should is just shorthand for how we
speak with one another and try to
admonish one another to be better in the
future in order to cooperate better or
to realize different outcomes but it's
not a deep principle of reality what is
a deep principle of reality is
consciousness and its possibilities
consciousness is the one thing that
can't be an illusion even if we're in a
simulation even if we're brains and vats
even if we're confused about everything
something seems to be happening and that
seeming is the fact of consciousness and
almost as rudimentary as that is the
fact that within this space of Siemens
again we don't know what the base layer
of reality is we don't know if our
physics is the real physics
we could be confused if this could be a
dream we could be confused about
literally everything except that in the
space of Siemens there appears to be a
difference between things getting truly
awful - no apparent good end and things
getting more and more sublime and
there's potentially even a place to
stand where that difference isn't so
captivating anymore
certainly there are Buddhists who would
tell you that you can step off that
wheel of opposites ultimately but even
if you buy that that is some version of
a peak on my moral landscape that is a
contemplative peak where you know the
difference between agony and ecstasy is
no longer distinguishable because what
you are then aware of is just that
consciousness is intrinsically free of
its content
no matter what its possible content
could be if someone can stabilize that
intuition more more power to them but
then that's the thing you should do just
to bring it back to the conventional
moral framing yeah I agree with you the
I'm generally a realist about
consciousness and still do feel very
confused not just because reasons in
this conversation but just generally
about how causality fits in there and
how it might influence our understanding
of the worst possible misery for
everyone being a bad thing I'm also
willing to go that far to accept that as
objectively a bad thing if bad means
anything but then I still get really
confused about how that necessarily fits
in with say decision theory or should in
the space of possible minds and what is
compelling to who and why perhaps this
is just semantics imagine all these
different minds that have different
utility functions you know the paper
clip Maximizer wants nothing more than
paper clips and anything that reduces
paper clips is perceived as a source of
suffering it has a disutility if you
have any utility function you have this
liking and not liking component provided
you're sentient well that's what it is
to be motivated consciously for me the
worst possible misery for everyone is a
condition where whatever the character
of your mind every sentient mind
is put in the position of maximal
suffering for it so some things like
paper clips and some things hate paper
clips if you hate paper clips would give
you a lot of paper clips if you like
paper clips we take away all your paper
clips if that's your mind we tune your
corner of the universe to that torture
chamber
you can be agnostic as to what the
actual things are that make something
suffer it's just suffering is by
definition the ultimate frustration of
that Minds utility function okay I think
that's a really really important crux
and crucial consideration between us and
a general point of confusion here
because that's the definition of what
suffering is or what it means
I suspect that those things may be able
to come apart so for you
maximum disutility and suffering are
identical but I guess I could imagine a
utility function being separate or
inverse from the hedonic s-- of a mind
like maybe the utility function which is
purely a computational thing isgetting
maximally satisfied maximizing suffering
everywhere and the mind that is
implementing that suffering is just
completely a misery at while doing it
but the utility function which is
different and inverse from the
experience of the thing is just getting
satiated and so the machine keeps
driving towards maximum suffering world
right but there's either something that
is like to be satiated in that way or
there isn't right now if we're talking
about real conscious satiety we're
talking about some higher-order
satisfaction or pleasure that is not
suffering by my definition we have this
utility function ourselves I mean we
take somebody who decides to climb to
the summit of Mount Everest where the
process almost every moment along the
way is synonymous with physical pain and
intermittent fear of death torture by
another name but the whole project is
something that they're willing to train
for sacrifice for dream about and then
talk about for the rest of their lives
and at the end of the day might be in
terms of their conscious sense of what
it was like to be them the best thing
they ever did in their lives that is
this sort of by layered utility function
your
right where you could just experience
sample what it's like to be in the Death
Zone on Everest it really sucks
and if imposed on you for any other
reason it would be torture but given the
framing given what this person believes
about what they're doing given the view
out there goggles given their identity
as a mountain climber this is the best
thing they've ever done
you're imagining some version of that
but that fits in my view on the moral
landscape that's not the worst possible
misery for anyone the source of
satisfaction that is deeper than just
bodily sensory pleasure every moment of
the day
or at least it seems to be for that
person at that point in time they could
be wrong about that there could be
something better they don't know what
they're missing it's actually much
better to not care about mountain
climbing the truth is your aunt is a
hell of a lot happier than Sir Edmund
Hillary was and Edmund Hillary was never
in a position to know it because he was
just so into climbing mountains that's
where the realism comes in in terms of
you not knowing what you're missing but
I just see any ultimate utility function
if it's accompanied by consciousness it
can't define itself as the ultimate
frustration of its aims if its aims are
being satisfied I see yeah so this just
seems to be a really important point
around hedonic sand computation and
utility function and what drives what so
wrapping up here I think I would feel
defeated if I let you escape without
maybe giving a yes or no answer to this
last question do you think that bliss
and well-being can be mathematically
defined you know that is something I
have no intuition about I'm not enough
of a math head to think in those terms
if we mathematically understood what it
meant for us neuro physiologically in
our own substrate well then I'm sure we
can characterize it for creatures just
like us
I think substrate independence makes it
something that's hard to functionally
understand you know in new systems and
it'll just pose problems of our just
knowing what it's like to be something
that on the outside seems to be
functioning much like we do but he's
organized in a very different
but yeah I don't have any intuitions
around that one way or the other
all right and so pointing towards your
social media are the best places to
follow you or should we do that my
websites just Sam Harris dead org and
I'm Sam Harris org without the dot on
Twitter and you can find anything you
want about me on my website certainly
all right Sam thanks so much for coming
on speaking this wide range of issues
you've been deeply impactful in my life
since I guess about high school I think
you probably partly at least motivated
my trip to Nepal where I overlooked the
pokhara lake and reflected on your
terrifying trip there that's hilarious
that's in my book waking up but it's
also on my website and it's also I think
I read it on the waking up app and it's
in a podcast it's also on Tim Ferriss
his podcast but anyway that acid trip
was detailed in this piece called drugs
and the meaning of life that's hilarious
I haven't been back to poke or a since
so you've seen that lake more recently
than I have so yeah you've contributed
much to my intellectual and ethical
development and thinking and for that I
have tons of gratitude and appreciation
and thank you so much for taking time to
speak with me about these issues today
nice well it's been a pleasure Lucas and
all I can say is keep going you're
working on very interesting problems and
you're very early to the game so it's
great to see you doing it thanks so much
Sam if you found this podcast
interesting or useful consider sharing
it on social media forums with friends
or wherever you think it might be found
valuable we'll be back again next month
with another episode in the FLI podcast
[Music]